uh how do you feeling about just La
hip-hop right now man because you were
part of an era that was like I think of
you I think RJ I think just that whole
class that was you guys are kind of like
veterans now which is kind of crazy but
you know I feel like LA right now is in
a place where
a lot more people are working together
than I feel like it used to be even
though they're still separation of
politics and all that man we got to but
you know I feel like a lot of these
younger kids are kind of like embracing
each other a little bit more than I've
you know seen in previous I guess uh
classes but how are you feeling about
work I think I think that you know and I
love all the new guys that are out you
feel me shout out to Beano uh shout out
to blast shout out to blue bug shout out
to Kalyn for real for real Ruchi
um who am I miss who am I missing give
me some names one take Jay one take uh
AZ child yellow Hills dope oh yeah hey
yellow heels doing this thing it's only
a matter of time for yellow here it's
only a matter of time for yellow
um who am I missing who am I missing a
lot of even Ralphie man Ralphie be
killing it I love I love Ralphie music
you know what I'm saying
um baby Stone gorillas
um you know what Perico's still holding
it down too you got to get Perico his
credit killing it he's killing you gotta
give him his credit
um
it's a it's a lot of it's a lot of dope
guys right here and shout out to the
[__] in the IE team hey that's
somebody who could do a podcast
jeeperico Rico's funny as hell he's so
funny oh yeah no but I feel like now you
know how music translates now in the
city is way more harder because I was a
hot new hip-hop baby you feel me like I
got discovered on how new hip-hop right
and I had my you know when I felt like I
needed to drop albums they're right
there front page that piff right right
there how new hip hop and the discovery
for new artists now was just so [__]
hard it's like everybody chasing Tick
Tock but they ain't really organic like
that you know what I'm saying chasing
that yeah you might catch a moment but
you ain't got no friends concert tickets
yeah and I mean now the club scene is so
[__] dry it's whack and that's how we
got our records out there yeah for sure
you send me them supper clubs them
playhouses you'll be able to go to La
club and hear some [__] and be like oh
what's this yeah everybody knows it
everybody knows and then you go back
home and you learning that [__] but like
like and that's how like you know the
bookings and stuff like that that's what
kept us afloat yeah the club [__] out
here I mean and listen I'm to the point
in my life where I don't go out unless
I'm getting paid or unless it's like an
event that it really makes sense for me
to go so I'm kind of like I just
remember like
I feel like since the pandemic the club
scene has yet to fully really rebound
the way it was for for like local La
hip-hop music I'd have been [__] right
now I don't know like I I hear that
there's some spots like I know that the
LA function is cool to La function
Supreme Team
dragonfly too yeah but but I mean like
as far as the impact it's not there like
people used to play I want to go to LA
to go to supper
clubs yeah and right now on some fly
type [__] I mean you know shout out to
my guy uh uh uh Scott I mean my guy um
um Sean my bad I said Scott uh
Wednesday's highlight room you feel me
yeah Dickerson Dickerson my guy Sean
Dickerson I said Scott what's that Sadiq
right Sadiq be booming yeah but that's
but that's not that's more that's not
nobody not a lot of people can get into
that no no no no nobody and they're not
playing no L.A music they're not playing
no la music no it's a Vibe it's a Vibe
though and you'll run into The Who's Who
of the world yeah but there's no like La
culture up there no but La culture wise
like
I feel like
we all have to stick together now you'll
have to do music with each other now
you'll have to do concerts with each
other now because I've been loving all
the shows they've been happening at the
Roxy yeah it's been dope it's been super
dope it's like I talked to Caitlin
yesterday he about to go back on tour
shout out to Kayla yeah we got a fire
record coming out oh that's gonna be the
first thing I dropped coming back you
and Kalyn me and Kayla for real for real
I mean you've been dropping records
though you're here and there yeah just a
test of waters and see how the climate
is like yeah I mean dude you're you're
bigger than you've ever been yeah so the
music is gonna but that's the that's the
thing like if you think okay so you
think about the process of music now
right and I own a studio now yeah so
let's eliminate owning the studio you
have to book studio time you have to pay
the producer you have to do the song you
got to get it mixed you got to get it
mastered you got to do the video you got
to put it out and hopefully and then you
gotta figure out a way to make money off
of that because you're already for
people who don't know 3 900 every
million streams on Spotify that's it so
and you have to hope that it accumulates
that to get your investment bag versus I
can go downstairs and make three grand
tonight yo that's crazy so you know the
urgency of it is like you know I want to
put out [__] that I feel is perfect you
know it's dope I don't have to rush
anything there's no fillers in there and
we can sit there and see if this the
songs age over time because a lot of the
[__] I deal with Canon some of them
songs were almost three years old but it
still stands up and I mean John Cannon's
that guy come on the production but
that's the difference with the
production quality yeah you know I mean
like when you're a real producer
you can make them Timeless records and
you can bring the Beast out of artists
and stuff